[APPLAUSE]
SAMIR: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
I'm really excited to be
here today to talk to you
about an exciting
topic, which is AI.
My name is Samir.
I'm a gaming technical
specialist at Google Cloud.
And I'm based in Tokyo.
You might wonder
also, like, what's
a gaming technical specialist?
I have a lot of my
friends asking me
what I do in my daily job.
The answer is very simple.
I just play games.
But I'm not joking.
My co-workers are always
asking me, what are you doing?
They see on my phone
I'm just playing.
But no, more seriously,
I'm helping gaming studios
in Asia making innovative
backends on GCP.
So today, I'll be talking
to you about what we offer
in Google Cloud around AI.
But then I will give
the space to DeNA,
who are on the
stage with me today,
that will talk about
their experience
on how they simulated human
players in one of their more
popular games and building
that on a scalable and robust
backend on Google
Machine Learning Engine.
So they will come back on stage.
I'll do a bit of introduction.
And I think I don't even
have-- oh, yeah, this.
So they will come
back in a few minutes.
Thank you.
So Google is working
with the game industry
to help developers succeed.
And Cloud is at the
center of those efforts.
We want to help
create great games
and connect with players
globally and scale
your business.
So we're working with
other Google teams
to bring this vision to life.
So before diving into the
concrete implementation
of DeNA in the AI space,
let me talk to you
about different
applications of AI in games.
And I won't talk to
you about all of them,
but just a few
that I really like.
For instance, the first one--
being able to play against a bot
that simulates the pro players.
So wouldn't that be cool
to be able to compare
your skill to the best,
the very best in the game?
Usually, you don't
have the opportunity
to play against a pro player
if you're probably not one.
So isn't that cool to do that?
Think also, a
similar way, instead
of having a bot that
simulates a pro player,
it could simulate yourself.
And think about you're
playing a multiplayer
game against someone
online, and that person
that you play
against disconnects,
and the game ends prematurely.
Isn't that frustrating?
Me, I play a lot online,
and when it happens,
I feel really frustrated because
I wanted to end the game.
But think about if you had a bot
that could simulate yourself,
like the way you play.
So you're playing online,
your connection drops,
but you've been
replaced at that moment
by a bot that plays like you.
Your opponent might
not even notice
that he's playing against a
bot, and the game could end.
Wouldn't that be a
great user experience?
There's also use
cases that we'll
talk a bit later that don't
even require expertise in ML.
But I want you to realize that
AI has its place in games.
And it really helps increase
the user experience,
but also, in very critical
things, like monetization
or peer retention.
So not only the AI has
its place in the game,
but games are also an
ideal environment for AI.
So games plays a big part
on how we develop technology
in Google and Alphabet.
DeepMind is a very
good example of that.
DeepMind is an artificial
intelligence research company.
From Atari to the
ancient game of Go,
they use increasingly
challenging game environment
as a testing ground to develop
more capable and generalizable
systems that can navigate
through extreme complexity.
So the natural next step
in their research program
was the real-time
strategy game StarCraft.
So StarCraft 2, because it
posed yet more hard problems
to solve in areas
of computer science,
like planning, dealing
with uncertainty,
and special reasonings.
I don't know if you have seen
what has been done recently
with the StarCraft bid.
They could make a bot that
could beat the top pro player
of StarCraft 2.
So that's really impressing
how you go, how they have done.
And you can see the vision
of how AI is going in game.
So unfortunately, not
everyone is DeepMind,
and not everyone has
their ML experts.
The data is overwhelming.
The world is lacking
of ML experts.
From the 21 million
developers, you
have less than a million data
scientists and even less ML
experts.
So our goal on the
Google Cloud is
to help anyone use
Machine Learning
to build new applications
or to add intelligence
to existing ones.
We've taken the best of Google
Machine Learning and offer it
as a fully-trained model via
accessible [? VR ?] API's.
So all of our
pre-trained models are
built on years of Google
expertise and refined training
data.
From vision recognition to
natural language processing,
you can use our API to
teach your application
to see, hear, or
interact with users
in a complete different way.
So what are the different
AI journeys that
are offered by Google Cloud?
There is a few.
If you see on the top,
the prepackaged solution--
so we have prepackaged yet
powerful AI solutions for games
to draw new on their AI pass,
with very limited resource
or very limited ML expertise.
On the bottom part, for advanced
studios with AI journey-- like,
advanced on their AI journey--
who has data scientists or ML
experts that can build and
train ML models themselves
using TensorFlow, Cloud TPU, or
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And then, in the middle,
you have a new pathway
that's supposed to help you
onboard on machine learning,
and do more advanced stuff
without even that ML expertise.
So you will find Cloud AutoML.
So Cloud AutoML
helps game studios
with limited ML
expertise to start
building their own high-quality
models, but using a GUI.
And on the right side,
you'll find BigQuery ML.
So BigQuery, for those
that are not very familiar,
it's a data warehouse
that Google Cloud
is offering on their cloud.
And it offers an
additional functionality
where you can create
machine learning models
just using standard SQL.
So solutions like Cloud
AutoML or BigQuery ML,
they're here to make even AI
expert be more productive,
but even help--
and it will also help
the less-skilled engineer
that are not very familiar with
ML to build powerful AI systems
that they could only
dream of previously.
So this is the only sales
speech that I will put today
in my presentation-- just
telling you why customers
are choosing Google for AI.
I will go very quickly over it.
So there's four points.
One is scale.
So we offer a cloud called
Google Cloud Platform.
You start using our
cloud, you get access
to thousands of instances.
So if you have heavy
computational workload,
you get access to the compute
that you need to do that.
Two, the speed.
So Google Cloud is the only
one to offer what we call TPUs.
So I don't know if you have
ever heard of what a "TPU" is.
It sounds like a CPU, GPU.
So TPU is a Tensor
Processing Unit.
So it's a process
[? sword ?] that we custom
made for the machine
learning use case.
But to understand
how faster is it--
usually when you
train a model, most
of the time you
will use a GPU too
have a higher
computational power.
And if you compare
what Cloud TPU can do,
using a ResNet 50 model
you can benchmark it,
and using a single Cloud TPU--
which is eight cores
and 64 gig of RAM--
it goes 8.4 times faster
than an Nvidia P100 GPU,
and it still goes five times
faster than an Nvidia V100 GPU.
So it's extremely fast.
If you try with other Inception
models, like Inception V3,
you get similar results.
So Google Cloud is the only
one to offer the Cloud TPU,
and can really accelerate your
machine learning workload.
The third one is quality.
I think you have already
tried Google Photo, Google
Translator, Google Assistant.
And you can see how
accurate Google Photo can
be when you start searching
for anything that you have
in your Google Photo albums.
I often search
"hamburger," because I
like to show to my friend the
last hamburger I've eaten.
And I put "hamburger," and I
get the list of all the burgers
that I ate in the past.
It's very accurate.
So even when you search
a card-- at some time,
I took photo of my
ID or my credit card,
and I put "card"
or "ID," and I will
find those photos that otherwise
I wouldn't be able to find.
Accessibility, this one
is the tool product.
Like, outside the pre-trained
model that we are offering,
we have the
intermediate solution,
like Cloud AutoML
and BigQuery ML,
that will help you make ML
more accessible to everyone.
So to conclude my part, I
have just only three words,
"don't miss out."
AI is at your fingertips, and
you can start right now adding
intelligence to
your application--
like existing ones,
or to a new one--
using those pre-trained
model or even custom model
using Cloud AutoML.
If you are already an
ML expert, then you
can jump directly to
TensorFlow Cloud ML Engine
to run your own custom model.
So this is enough for my side.
Without further ado, I want
to introduce you to folks
from DeNA that will talk
about their experience
creating an AI and a deck
recommendation system
in one of their most popular
mobile games in Japan on GCP.
So I'll let Jun continue
this presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JUN: So thank you, thank you,
Samir, for the introduction.
And we're from DeNA, which
is one of the largest game
publishers in Japan.
And today, we would like to
share our AI implementation
on gaming.
So far, we have released
two applications that we're
going to talk about-- the
motivation implementation,
and the outcomes of our cases.
So my name is Jun Ernesto,
and I'm leading this project.
Also, let me
introduce Ikki Tanaka.
He's a data scientist,
and built our AI models.
So in this part, both
of us will present.
So to begin with, this
work has been accomplished
by four machine learning
engineers, and lots
of collaborators
from gaming team.
Each of us have our
own area of expertise,
and I really love this team.
So let's start.
So I think most of you are
not so familiar with DeNA.
Our company is one of
the largest internet
companies in Japan.
Although we have various
business domains, such as game,
automotive, and sports, most of
the revenue comes from games.
Actually, we're providing
dozens of in-house game titles,
and the other
publishers' titles.
Maybe some of you
may know that we
have an alliance with Nintendo.
For example, our company is in
charge of the backend system
from "Super Mario Run."
So this is who we are.
In this session, we'll focus
on the in-house game title
"Gyakuten Othellonia."
So, first, I'd like to talk
about the program we had,
and how we challenged
to solve these issues.
So this game,
"Gyakuten Othellonia,"
is a strategy app game.
The player's action is based on
the board game called "Othello"
or "Reversi," and the players
put black on white pieces
alternatively.
What is unique
about this game is
that each piece has
its own skills, which
adds strategic components
to the battles.
Actually, when you
start playing the game,
there are a variety play
starts, and endless exploration
is required to master the game.
This title was released
three years ago,
and fortunately,
it's still growing.
We have more than 23
million downloads so far,
and the service region
is expanding gradually.
And of course, I
hope in the future we
can release in the US, as well.
So in "Othellonia,"
there is the concept
of decks and the characters.
Before starting a battle,
player [? constructs ?]
a deck which is composed
of 16 characters among more
than 3,000 options.
And each character
has its own skills,
and the players have to choose
consistent characters according
to their play styles.
As you can imagine, the number
of combinations is extreme,
and it's not easy for
beginners to learn
how to build an optimal deck.
Another issue here is that
building an optimal deck
requires to learn effective
strategies through the process
of trial and error.
So let me explain why
this is a problem.
Generally speaking, if the
game has complex features which
can distract players
from continuing the game,
the churn rate increases, and
impacts the future revenue.
Right?
For example, there
is an estimation
that just a few points decrease
in the 30-day churn rate
can increase the revenue by
20% to 30% in the future.
Back to "Othellonia,"
we actually
have a high churn rate,
so we are in trouble.
This is partly because the
game is complex, and lacks
sufficient [INAUDIBLE] support.
Therefore, it's
hard for beginners
to construct an optimal deck.
Also, there is the
problem that they
don't have a good
place for practice
in order to improve
their battle skills.
For instance, we only have two
battle options for beginners.
One is NPC battle, in which
they battle against very, very
weak opponents, and the
other is PvP battle,
in which they are frequently
matched with skilled players.
So we needed an opponent
whose play level is similar
to the beginner's.
So that's our opponent setting.
So let's see our approach.
To support beginners, we
have developed two functions.
The first one is the deck
recommendation system,
which selects appropriate
characters from players' piece
box, and we are using the
association analysis to provide
a better recommendation.
The second one is Battle AI,
which we call Othellonia Dojo.
In this function, we developed
AI that can play at any levels.
A deep neural network
is used for this AI.
Later, Ikki will explain
how these techniques
are used in our cases.
So, by the way, from the
machine learning perspective,
we need to prepare the
data to build such AIs.
We are collecting various
kind of in-game data
since the release of the game,
such as deck logs and battle
logs.
So we have a good amount of data
before starting this project.
So in our cases,
we used the data
for the last nine
months, which contains
billions of log entries.
And then we filtered the
data by player skills,
and augmented the original
data in the battle AI cases.
The image on the right
side is an example
of a battle log, which
is formatted in JSON,
and describes enter
states and action
information of the battle.
The bottom diagram shows
a rough data pipeline,
and BigQuery did a very good job
at this pre-processing phase.
For instance, it can handle
even a terabyte order of data
very fast, and we could
reduce the processing time
drastically.
BQ could handle our data in a
few minutes, which took an hour
on on-prem Hadoop clusters.
And we also love that BQ is easy
to collaborate with other GCP
services.
So here I want to stress that
our AI has been successfully
built by sufficient amount of
data and a reliable pipeline.
So let's see how each
of the cases works.
This is a very rough overview of
the deck recommendation system.
So we first exploit
a pre-process deck
log to extract information
about how each characters are
associated, which is
called associational rules.
With this analysis, we
can score the strength
of the relationship across
all the pairs of characters.
Then, if there is a
request from the player,
the recommendation
server receives
a set of characters in
the player's piece box,
and it fills all of
the 16 characters
according to their score
of the associational rules.
This function is very
flexible, and the player
can specify deck
archetype, deck cost,
and their favorite characters
to be included in the deck.
Regarding KPIs, we are
monitoring several metrics.
For instance, we are
watching how many players
have used the
recommendation system,
whether the recommended
deck has been accepted,
and whether the deck contributed
to the players in terms
of their win rate in battles.
So as for the Dojo, players
can battle against AI
with various archetypes
and strengths.
Here we train a
deep neural network
from preprocessed battle logs.
The clients send
current game status,
and the battle
API server returns
the inference of neural network
at every turn of the game.
As for the metrics,
we are monitoring
how frequently the Dojo is
used, and whether the strength
of the AI was sufficient
in terms of win rate.
So these two AIs have
already been released,
and we are observing
very positive KPIs.
So before showing the results,
I'll pass the talk to Ikki.
He'll talk about the technical
details, and some tips
for building AI systems.
[APPLAUSE]
IKKI: Thank you, Jun.
So hello.
I'm Ikki, and a data
scientist at DeNA.
So I am one of the developers
that created our gaming AI
system by using data analysis,
data science, and machine
learning.
So today, I'll talk about the
technical details of our use
cases with GCP.
So now, let's look at the
story of the technical part.
So first, I'd like to
standardize our deck
recommendation.
This is the outline of the
deck recommend algorithm.
And firstly, the deck
recommendation algorithm
receives some input from a
player, such as deck archetype,
deck cost, their possessed
characters, and the characters
the player wants to use.
Next, the algorithm
selects a leader
by using the result
of association
analysis and statistical data.
So in this algorithm, the leader
character is chosen first,
and the next characters are
selected based on the leader.
The well-associated
characters are simply
selected based on the result
of association analysis.
If the deck is not full
of the 16 characters,
another character is selected
as the best character.
After repeating this
procedure several times,
the recommended deck is
proposed to the player.
If the game is different,
the way of fine-tuning
is also different.
So in our game,
"Gyakuten Othellonia,"
for example, we made additional
rules to decide a leader,
and we checked its
activation with the skills
in deck building.
I'd like to give a
brief explanation
about how to extract
the relationships
between characters.
In our recommendation, we are
using association analysis.
The association analysis
is a rule-based machine
learning method for discovering
interesting relations
between contents
in large datasets.
So this method can perform
high-speed calculation
to extract the
main relationships,
and extracted relations are
easy to understand and very
useful in various settings.
The relations are evaluated
with some metrics,
like the strength of the
connections and frequency
of the rules or patterns.
Our recommendation builds a
deck by selecting a character
sequentially with strong
relationships, one
after another.
So this method can handle
various kinds of data easily.
So I think this technique
is applicable to many games.
Next, I will talk
about the system.
So we built our application
such as deck recommendation
and the deep learning
AI bot with GCP.
So why did we choose
GCP for our ML systems?
There are two main reasons.
The first one is powerful
and flexible tools
for machine learning
and data science.
In the data analysis, we often
try to investigate the data,
visualize it, and create
the prototype models.
GCP services for
big data analysis
make it possible for us, such
as BigQuery, Cloud Datalab,
and Google Compute Engine.
The GCP services
for cloud storage
provides scalable and faster
services for large data.
And it helps us to manage the
big data and a lot of machine
learning models.
About Cloud ML engine, we
can deploy the AI models
to Cloud ML engine
easily and quickly.
And it also provides
user-friendly prediction APIs.
Additionally, GCP provides many
services to perform machine
learning efficiently.
For example, we are planning to
use the GKE content of service
and Cloud ML Engine training
with custom functions
for scalable and
distributed ML training.
The second one is scalable and
robust infrastructure services.
We can run the
application easily
by using Google App Engine with
several programming languages,
like the Python Go language.
And we can check many metrics
of system performances
through stack Stackdriver,
Logging, and so on.
I'd like to emphasize the
auto-scaling function of GAE
is very great service, because
new instances are increased
or stopped in
response to traffic.
And the [INAUDIBLE] are
distributed to the instances
automatically.
So this GCP service
is easy to integrate
into the same systems.
So for these reasons, we are
choosing GCP for our ML system.
I'll show the system
architecture of deck
recommendation with GCP.
First, the deck logs are
saved in BigQuery, which
are used to extract the rules.
We send the [INAUDIBLE] schedule
to performance the batch
processing of the association
analysis in Google Compute
Engine.
And in order to catch
up the trained decks
with latest characters, we are
performing the batch processing
every day.
Then Cloud Functions
preprocesses the result
of association analysis,
and updates the data
for production environment.
Cloud Functions checks if the
data is updated correctly--
for example, if the deck
size is too small or large.
And we are using Google
App Engine Python
3.7 for the
recommendation API server.
The server receives a
request from a client,
then builds the
deck, and finally, it
returns the recommended
deck to the player.
One of the noteworthy
point is GAE Python
3.7 was generally available
at the end of last year,
so we could use it
just at the right time.
As a result of that
[? wait ?] to Python 3.7,
we don't need to change our
code that we had already
developed in Python 3.
So far, I've explained the
algorithm and the system
of deck recommendation.
Let's move on to
the next topic--
Deep-Learning AI-Bot.
It's Othellonia Dojo.
"Dojo" means a training room to
improve their playing skills.
This is an overview of the
training in Deep Learning AI
Bot.
The branding is
suitable for our case
to learn the many complicated
features, such as state
of board, decks, hands,
skills, and combinations
of the features.
The Deep Learning AI
Bot receives a state
of battles from a client.
The information of
battle is converted
to the numerical
features, which are
used as the inputs
of the Deep Learning.
The network learns the
actions of top-tier players
as binary classification.
And finally, the
Deep Learning model
outputs the values of
each action that will be
used to decide the next action.
Here we used more than
10 million battle records
in the training.
Next, I will show
the system of AI Bot.
First of all, I'll talk
about the training phase.
A large number of
battle records in PvP
is saved in Google Cloud
Storage through BigQuery.
And the training
process consists
of preprocessing of the
features and the model training,
which are running in
Google Compute Engine.
At the preprocessing,
the features
are generated on demand
from the battle records
by emulating the game.
In our case, we created
the custom function
of Data Generator that creates
a feature during the training.
After the training,
the trained AI model
is saved in Cloud Storage
to deploy onto the Cloud ML
Engine.
Next, I move on to
the inference phase.
So please take a look
at the communication
between the client
inference API server
on the left of the slide.
The battle records are posted
to the inference API server
from the client, which plays
a battle event against AI bot.
The inference API server
reproduces a battle
from the record,
extracts the features,
and it sends those features
to the online prediction
API with Cloud ML Engine.
Online prediction
of Cloud ML Engine
is very useful,
because it is optimized
to run the AI models with
low [INAUDIBLE] in real time.
Cloud ML Engine uses the
trained AI model starting in DCS
and returns the
values of each action.
The values are sent
back to the client,
and the client moves
towards the battle step
by selecting a best action
according to the values.
That's the overall
communication between the client
and the servers.
Google App Engine
and Cloud ML Engine
can auto-scale in response
to the load on the server.
That's a very good function.
So by taking the benefit
of the auto-scaling,
we can manage a large
amount of requests.
Lastly, I'll touch on
the technical topic--
the testing of the systems.
So why should we
test the systems?
I mentioned in the last slide,
Cloud ML Engine can auto-scale
quickly--
that's good.
So yes, that's true.
But we didn't have enough
knowledge about how much load
the system withstand.
In the mobile game,
generally, the load
tends to increase at the
moment a new event opens.
The figure on the
slide shows an example
of estimated requests per
second in a yardstick event.
This is a trial calculation.
The requests per second will
increase to several hundreds
in 10 minutes.
We have to check in
advance if the system can
withstand this load.
As a point of notice, we cannot
predict the action of the AI
as a batch processing
at regular intervals.
Our system has to
respond to the request
from the player in real time.
That is where the AI should put
the character in the next turn.
To achieve this, we chose
the Online Prediction API
of the Cloud ML Engine.
We've checked if the Cloud
ML Engine can satisfy
our requirements by
performing the load
testings in advance of release.
In our case, the
testing was performed
in the setting and the requests
increase linearly and reach
a maximum of 1,000
requests per second.
We found the Cloud ML Engine can
auto-scale quickly in response
to the requests, and the average
latency of the prediction
is less than one second.
However, there are
a few requests that
took a longer time than usual.
Since this might not be possible
to request to the player,
so we needed to
resolve this condition.
Our DeNA team and
Cloud ML Engine team
cooperated to investigate
the bottlenecks.
And then we found the
timeout has happened
when the new instances of app in
the process of the auto-scaling
due to our heavy load.
It is challenging to handle a
large number of requests which
consists of many features
at the same time with online
[? prediction. ?] But if
we can resolve this problem
by building an efficient
but consistent,
we don't have to warm up
the system beforehand,
and the system will
be more robust.
So our team took our time
to deal with this problem.
Let's take a look at we
tackled to remove the errors.
When the error
returns within a time
we can simply throw it
back again to the servers.
But in the case of a timeout,
the system cannot send it back
again, because a timeout
error is not returned.
Therefore, when the
inference API server does not
receive the response
within five seconds,
the request is sent
back to the API
again, because something bad
has happened in the inference.
Also, if the destination of the
request is the same end point,
it will further increase
the load on the server.
As a result, we set on
the backup end point
to receive the request
that fails to be
operated in the main endpoint.
That is, the second
request is sent
to the backup endpoint, which
is prepared independently
from the main endpoint.
This is the result of load
testing with backup endpoint.
The figure shows the error
rate of several settings--
no backup, backup
with 10 minimum nodes,
and backup with
20 minimum nodes.
In the case without backup
endpoint, on the left,
about 1.3% of errors remain.
In the middle setting of the
backup with 10 minimum nodes,
although small errors
still remained,
the backup can deal with most
of the main endpoint errors.
We found the reason
of these small errors
is because the number of backup
instances was small a bit.
So the timeout
has still happened
at the warm-up of
the auto-scaling
in the backup environment.
So right most cases
of fine tune setting,
where the number
of backup instances
was set to 20 for covering
the errors of main endpoint
substantially.
In this case, we could
handle all the requests
without errors.
So in this way, DeNA and
the Cloud ML Engine team
got over the challenge of high
and spiky traffic and latency
limit without errors.
After deployment,
this system has been
stable in handling many errors.
So far, I've explained the
[INAUDIBLE] system of our AI,
and the system with GCP
can be constructed flexibly
to cope with various
programs for gaming.
So now I'd like to hand
over to Jun for the KPI
result and the future.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JUN: Yeah.
Thank you, Ikki.
And I think you mentioned, we
needed a scalable and robust
system to actually implement
this AI in the real cases.
So in this final
part, I would like
to share what happened
after the release.
So first, for the
deck recommendation,
here is a chart which shows
the number of beginners
who use deck recommendation.
There were constant usage after
the release, but at this time,
this function was
not well-known.
But the station has
been changed after we
started an in-game
event to promote
players to build new decks.
The deck recommendation system
has been recognized more,
and even after the
event has been finished,
many players are still using
this function frequently.
So second, we are very glad
that the recommended deck pushed
the win rate of the
beginners by about 5%
compared to decks created
without the recommendation
system.
Since our focus was
to support beginners,
we are very satisfied
with these results.
Also, I'd like to mention that
this function has good adoption
even for top-tier players.
This was sort of
byproduct, but we're
observing that heavy
players usually
update their deck frequently.
And this recommendation
system mitigates the cost
of building deck from scratch.
They use recommendation
as a first edition,
and then customize
the deck as they want.
So let's look at the
system metrics, as well.
After the release, we
have a stable latency
of 20 milliseconds, which is
very fast enough for our cases.
But we are very
surprised by the result,
because the recommendation
algorithm is very complex,
and we haven't expected
such a low latency.
The auto-scaling does
a good job, as well,
and we haven't had any
system trouble so far.
So briefly, we will explain
about the evaluation
of Deep Learning AI Bot.
After the release,
we are observing
that our AI Bot has good
enough win rate as a practice
partner for beginners.
Our AI Bot can beat
even top-tier players,
and therefore, the players
can choose any levels of AI
as a sort of mentor.
Although this was
released last week,
and we don't have enough data
to evaluate the business impact,
Dojo is used by
beginner very well,
and we hope this can lead
good KPI in the future.
So as to the latency, the
inference of Machine Learning
Engine is about 200
to 300 milliseconds,
and they're very
fast and stable.
Even for the entire
system, the response time
is about a second, which is
enough fast for our case.
Backup endpoint is working
well, and we haven't
had any system trouble so far.
So to the end of my
talk, I'll show items
which worked well in our cases.
So to train the AI that
played the game like a human,
we needed a battle log
that completely reproduced
battle status and actions.
So if you have some random
effects in the game,
make sure that the random
seeds are stored in the logs.
Secondly, for the
evolution of our AI,
we needed to run
thousands of battles
to get performance statistics.
Headless simulator helped
us a lot in this context.
If you want to try to use
reinforcement learning
techniques, you also
need very fast simulator,
because the number of
battles that our version goes
through really matters.
And third, we also
want to stress
that scalable and robust system
is required for implementing
AI in real services.
We think that GCP--
in particular, Machine
Learning Engine and GAE--
were a good choice for us.
The last item is not
technical, but critical.
Generally speaking, we don't
know how well AI will perform
and how big the
business impact will
be before starting a project.
So in such an
uncertain situation,
the communication
and controlling
the expectation
is very important.
Although we are machine
learning engineers,
we try to understand the
game and the business issue
correctly.
And I think that this was
a key factor of the success
of these projects.
So this is from me, and I'd like
to pass the summary to Samir
again.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMIR: Yes.
Thank you, Jun-san and Ikki-san,
for this amazing presentation.
I think it's inspired a
lot of people here today,
and it's very
impressive, the work
they have done to make
their game a bit more
inclusive and a bit more
friendly to beginners.
And I hope that what
they have implemented
will be very successful, and
that today's presentation
can help you, maybe,
have some ideas.
And so, before
closing this session,
I want just to show
you some simple use
case that you could start
with using machine learning.
And I will talk quickly
about two that don't much
require any expertise,
and one that's very
similar to what they have done.
So starting by this one,
the chat translation.
So one of the big problem in
games is the language barrier.
And so I strongly see that in
the regions where I come from--
Japan, where players are
just speaking Japanese.
And you will never
see a game that
has multiple community
of people from Japan
playing with Korean
and Taiwanese people,
because the language.
And so if you want to
break that barrier,
you can start by using this
kind of pre-trained model,
like Translation
API, to translate
chat messages in real time, and
to break those kind of barrier.
It would be so good to have
more integrated community
within the game that
could go beyond frontiers.
So this is one use case
that you could really
start very quickly.
And if you have ever
tried the translation--
Google Translation-- you
see that it's very accurate.
And even though it might not
be perfect in the language
of a game, it will still be
better than having communities
that cannot communicate
with each other.
The second one is one that I
see every gaming company trying
to fight, is the
player toxicity.
Sometimes in your
game, you might
have some people that might
bully some other player,
and that can break
a bit the game.
And so you don't want to lose
important players because
of the bad players' behavior.
You could start on Google
Cloud Platform-- on GCP--
using Natural Language
Processing API.
That has a functionality
called Sentiment Analysis.
So what Sentiment
Analysis is doing is,
it would take a
text as an input,
and will be able
to tell you if it's
a positive input or a negative
input that has been done.
Based on a lot of data that
you would be able to take,
you could maybe detect very
negative insight from players,
and to warn them,
maybe to ban them,
if it's really at that point.
But you don't want,
maybe, to go manually
to check every single
chat or action of players
to decide if that
person is toxic.
You could get this
kind of API to bring
you insight on potential
problems in your game,
and potential players
that are dealing,
maybe, problems in
your game, and that
can damage it in the end.
So these are two use cases
that can be start very quickly,
using pre-trained models.
The last one, which will
require a bit more expertise,
and I think that's very similar
to what DeNA has done today,
is simplifying games.
And I think today,
what DeNA have done
is a perfect example of
what is simplification
of game using AI.
And they made their
deck recommendation
to simplify a bit the
construction of the games
when you have too many
characters, possibly.
And also, having a way
to train against a bot
is also a way to train
and help people ramp up.
So you could also think
from other use cases.
And one that I always
hear from studios
is the Q and A. So
the QA testing--
not Q and A. QA testing.
So QA testing costs
a lot of money,
because you need to test every
time you do some changes.
You need to test if this
doesn't break, for instance,
the balance of your game.
In the mobile space,
and even now in console,
because you start to see that
the latest game, like Fortnite,
gets weekly updates to bring
you new items in the game.
If you will be able to
automate this kind of testing,
you'll be able to
be sure that when
you bring a new item or
a new card in your game,
it doesn't break the
balance of the game.
And usually, I can see
from being in Japan,
and playing those
Japanese game on mobile
that brings new item, new
character every two weeks--
sometimes a character
will break the balance.
I even see on Fortnite,
sometimes they
bring a new weapon,
and it's too strong,
and they immediately
take action.
But you would like to
act before doing that,
before going in production
with your update.
If you'll be able to create
the automation, like they did,
that would be one
of the use cases
that could be interesting.
And I think to do
this kind of thing,
you'll be able to use
TensorFlow, Machine Learning
Engine, and do something very
similar to what DeNA did.
And I hope that what the
presentation from DeNA
inspired you and
gave you some insight
of how you bring and approach
a problem that's as complex as,
maybe, a human-simulated bot.
But I hope this will
be helpful for you.
And I think we have
a little time--
I think we have 10 minutes more.
So if you have any
questions, I think we're--
Ikki-san, Jun-san-- please
come up on the stage.
And if you have any
questions, I think
they have a mic in the back.
And feel free to ask question.
If you want to talk a bit more
deeper about something, or a
challenge that you've
been having, we can
discuss after the session.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Any question?
Ah.
AUDIENCE: First, thank
you for your talk.
When training your AI based
on different skill levels--
so to play against beginners
versus playing against
experts--
did you ask the Cloud
system, the ML system
for multiple inferences?
Or did you train it differently?
Did you train it on games for
people who lose frequently,
as opposed to just experts?
JUN: So your question
is that if we only
train with the top-tier
tier players [INAUDIBLE]??
Ah.
Yeah.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: You want to train
it so that it sometimes
loses to beginners.
So how did you
accomplish that goal?
JUN: You mean that--
to train the levels?
Yeah.
OK.
So we have invented some
schemes for that adjustment.
So we inference for every
turn the score of the move.
Right?
So if, for example,
there is ten moves,
we sort every latest score, and
we pick the most highest score,
up to--
I mean, to be strong.
Right?
But we are optimizing
that score by selecting
the second- and third-best
move in a certain probability,
and that's a hyper parameter,
and we are tuning manually
that parameter.
So that's why we are--
we could balance the levels
according to the player.
AUDIENCE: In building
the game bot,
did you use
reinforcement learning,
or improvised
learning, or maybe you
had different results
with different models?
JUN: So in this case, we are
not using, but we are trying.
Well, actually, the
[INAUDIBLE],, here,
is that the [? main ?] function
running is very unstable
to learn--
especially in this
kind of strategic game.
So while we are trying, but
the win rate is not so high,
like a supervised
learning AI bot.
SAMIR: Here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for your talk again.
So you had nine months of data,
and billions of logs to start.
If you were to put this
system into a brand-new game,
nine months is a very long
time, and a lot of players
may already come and churn.
So what would be an
ideal-- what would be sort
of the theoretical minimum?
Could you put this in at the
start and learn as you go?
Would you need to wait some
certain amount of time to
[? accomplish this? ?]
JUN: Yeah.
Actually, like, two
week or one month's data
is enough for our case.
So nine months is
a kind of buffer.
So I think it's too much
to use nine month's data.
But you are measuring
the [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: If you could--
moving this to
your next game, you
would have this at the startup?
JUN: Ah.
Yeah.
So in that case, maybe we
need like one month data,
or a few weeks' data,
before the training.
SAMIR: Any other questions?
Ah.
Over there.
Yes.
By the way, thank you for
the very good questions.
It's a very good point.
AUDIENCE: The nature of
the games, these days,
is that the rules of the games
change frequently-- especially
with game updates.
And that changes the nature of
how the bots should be playing.
How do you plan
to deal with that?
JUN: Yeah.
That's a good point.
And actually, we're releasing
a few characters every week,
and the game bots
change time by time.
But our deep learning frameworks
works even for that cases,
because--
well, just after using one
week or a few days' data,
the AI become to add up to--
how do you say--
the latest environments.
So there is kind of a one
week delay, but in this case,
I think we are acceptable.
So yeah.
That's answer for the question.
AUDIENCE: What other problems
are you trying to tackle?
JUN: So your question is
what's the problem, currently,
we have?
Or--
AUDIENCE: Is there any
other type of problem
that you're
considering tackling,
other than what you
presented today?
SAMIR: If there is any
other problem that you
want to solve using ML?
JUN: Ah.
Yeah, of course.
So I mentioned the importance
of machine learning.
But actually, we want
to keep the game balance
very stable, and before
releasing the characters.
Right?
So we want to implement
reinforcement learning engine
to learn the brand-new
characters before release,
and then check if the
balance is not too much--
I mean, strength, or strong or
weak, or something like that.
So that might be
the next challenge.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
In regards to your inputs,
what data are you discarding?
Are you using everything
you've captured
since the beginning, or
everything from the last patch,
for the last two patches--
or updates, rather?
JUN: Yeah.
Actually, we are using almost
everything-- information,
as I say this.
So we're using a
five-kilo feature--
exerted for the board.
Like what kind of
skills is activated,
or in the last
turn, what happened,
or something like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you at all
worried that the legacy data
kind of skews the AI,
or the choices, at all?
JUN: Um-- so sorry.
I think I missed your point.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
As you introduce
more characters,
more options,
this, that, are you
worried that the
very old data that
didn't know about
all this new stuff
kind of skews the
recommendations,
or what the AIs--
SAMIR: I guess if you
have a change in your game
functionality over time, how do
you handle the new type of data
that you didn't have before.
JUN: Yeah, that's the
biggest problem we have now.
And frankly, we are--
so every time we
release a new skill,
we are tuning the
feature extractor,
and making to
create new features.
But that operation
cost is very high,
so we want to somehow
optimize that process.
So that may be the next
challenge to solve.
SAMIR: Any other questions?
OK.
I think if you want to
talk a bit more in detail,
we're staying on the
left of the stage.
So feel free to come by
and ask any question.
Other than that, I want to
thank you, again, for today.
It was really great.
And thank everyone
for joining us today.
[APPLAUSE]